[موسيقى]
بعد المصادر تتحدث عن ان هذا الانخفاض سوف
يستمر قليلا ممكن ان يصل الى السعر
المتداول حاليا في السوق الموازي والذي
يتراوح ما بين الثمانيه وعشرين جنيها الى
29 جنيها للدولار قد يكون الاسراع في خطوه
خفض الجنين في الوقت الحالي وتتعلق ب ااا
شرح السيوله الدولاريه ايضا في مصر
وحاجاتها الى اتمام للصفقات التي همم
المرتقبه مع الصناديق الخليجيه التي تم
الحديث عنها منذ نهايه العام الماضي همم
صفقات خاصه بالصندوق السعودي
الصندوق السيادي السعودي الذي تحدث عن 10
مليار دولار همم استثمارات في مصر وايضا
الصندوق ال همم القطري الذي تحدث عن خمسه
مليارات دولار في مصر
تالي هذه الصفقات معلقه بسعر همم
طبيعي للجنيه وسعر يعبر عن القيمه عن
العرض والطلب على الدولار في مصر
[موسيقى]